the gyro can experience you know and
that's like Badr Hari that's that's his
whole deal yeah no he's just as wildly
fighting a guy he looked really
frightened read yeah yeah
we green man to read yeah that's a tough
fight for him cuz yeah Enrico is so
active yeah how long is that out as well
yeah how long he's been out two years
for you
yeah but but Rico is calling [ __ ]
Rico said he just wanted out of the
fight when Rico was on the podcast he's
like you look at him he goes he looks at
one elbow and their chances really yeah
what's that I said he wanted out he said
he wanted out he was getting [ __ ] up
yeah and he said he knew that I was
tuning him up you know and I don't know
I mean that's also Rico trying to [ __ ]
with him yeah getting his head but yeah
it's like I would have loved to see Badr
have a few fights and get real sharp he
had like one right yeah you have one
didn't he fight he fought heads II right
yeah a forehead secure I guess yeah
that's it if I did if I remember the
person thank you for long a favor and
pull up butter
I thought he fought long you didn't find
anybody else just heads he just had to
get in noria before long that was a last
fight in nonsense e that is stretch on
holiday mmm so head Z Rico we hasn't
fought since does that say he doesn't
fight say oh that's glory glory by
kidding he did fire blob his wish mail
lon but go pull up his Wikipedia record
his Wikipedia record he's definitely had
at least one fights along London it was
yeah well I think he said some why I
don't know I think he fought head Z
again again that make sense why I'd see
the first time he fought him I was
common second he kicks him in the face
any on the floor
that was a long show time okay what does
he go okay so you did fight so that was
a hit a no contest against head Z the
last fight what is that says decision
anonymous why does it say no contest I
thought it's something that's positive
ready to kick him on floor
Showtime like look at this it says
decision unanimous but says result no
contest
what the [ __ ] is that in blue as well
I've never seen yeah can you click on
that was it say alright yeah the fighter
so why you testing Badr Hari just look
at his Instagram that's enough you
should just give him a suspension based
on his Instagram like listen bro he's
jacked I mean go to Badajoz Instagram
he's about as shredded as like a
professional fighter is everything he's
in ridiculous shape in it so the with
this reco far they gonna test him I
wonder
yeah I mean he's obviously an incredible
physical condition but the thing like
look at him dude look at that [ __ ]
picture get [ __ ] [ __ ] come on son he's
on all the Mexican supplements he should
be wearing a sombrero in that looking
good but ER
I'm really excited about that fight by
us them I think it's in December I think
it's December 12
please don't test them just stop glory
stop it let it go let it go
but Syed is a good coach there's some
really good coaches in Holland no I say
Osama Alba el Joey got a really good
coaches man
[Applause]